prochain thème est un petit peu plus
lourd je vous le promets c'est pas une
blague même de mauvais goût vous allez
voir la fiche qu'on peut lire sur un
camion qu'on pouvait lire en tous les
cas dans le quartier latin ces dernières
heures
on va la voir dans un instant c'est pas
écrit en écriture inclusive mais c est
les étudiants et les étudiantes
romantique passion et pas de prêt
étudiant sortait avec un sugar daddy je
suis garé ma marine sugar mama
le site s'appelle riche mythe beautiful
drôlement le la riche rencontre le la
magnifique
en clair il s'agit de mettre en relation
et je mets des guillemets en d2 view de
vieilles riche avec des étudiants ou des
étudiantes fauché en pleine campagne
balances ton port qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire le plus grand dégoût et et on se
demande même comment comment c'est
possible
voilà comment est ce possible d'abord
d'avoir cette cette idée là oui sûrement
mais enfin c'est du proxénétisme même
pas déguiser et voilà il revient se
balader dans les rues devant les facs
oui c'est absolument de la prostitution
enfin je comprends même pas comment ça
peut arriver aujourd'hui parce que
attendez vous voulez quand même lire
lire ce que dit ce site un retrouver la
jeunesse grâce à la présence d'une jeune
femme pétillante vous vous sentirez dix
ans plus jeune est revigoré avec une
sugar baby ardente à vos côtés bon bah
voilà qui est clair
il ya deux hypothèses pour l'expliquer
ce poids des gens qui animent ce site
ont l'esprit beaucoup beaucoup pu
dérégler que le conseil d'état qu'il a
déjà un peu lorsqu'il prend la décision
qu'il a prise sur ploërmel
soit ce sont des grands finaux qui se
disent bon d'accord vu me faire taper
dessus mais je vais avoir une pub
d'enfer
tout le monde va découvrir mon site et
grâce à ça je vais faire des affaires
c'est le moulin et je peux pas vous dire
laquelle des hypothèses alors juste
fermé
enfin les lois en france qu'elle termine
l'incitation à la débauche
il ya des lois sur la protection des
mineurs et doit surtout alexis oui mais
enfin aller à djoko renvoya pas un
policier qui plutôt que mettre des pv
apparaît tel alexis vous avez la réponse
dans le figaro étudiant aujourd'hui on
apprend que des plaintes ont été déjà
été déposées dès 2014 la justice alors
avait classé la plainte sans suite
notamment d'une association qui lutte
contre le proxénétisme une association
de magistrats qui s'appelle équipes
d'action contre le proxénétisme est le
motif avancé ces essais site ne propose
pas de la prostitution mais de l'escort
c'est en tout cas ce qu'explique le
responsable de cette association de
magistrats il y avait porté plainte
qu'est ce qu'une autre chose après deux
temps cette émission l'administratif ici
à autre chose étonnante dans cette
affaire où ce jeu là mais j'assume est
votre réflexion c'est la réponse ce
matin de marlène schiappa à nos
confrères de sud radio justement sur
cette question sur 7 entre guillemets
subtilité on écoute c'est pas un bus de
prostitution et c'est là qu'est la
subtilité c'est que c'est présenté comme
un but de sites de rencontres entre
jeunes et personnes âgées et riche faire
personnes plus âgées et riche
effectivement c'est problématique ce
qu'il faut qu'on regarde c'est est ce
qu'il s'agit de rencontres consentie ou
est-ce qu'il s'agit effectivement de
proxénétisme et d'une forme d'incitation
à la prostitution ce qui là pourraient
tomber effectivement sous le coup de la
loi donc on est en train de regarder
très précisément les aspects juridiques
de jeu comprend pas ce qu'il y'a quand
même l'adjectif riche partir du moment
où il a un objectif riches
on parle bien d'argent à un moment donné
donc donc je comprends pas bien
ardent site qui touche sa part le site
qui tous à part c'est le maquereau le
riche c'est la [ __ ] dans le riche ses
clients et là les étudiants que c'est la
[ __ ]
soyons clair donc c'est vraiment son
couvert emmaüs owona je suis dans ma
blessure mais ça marche dans tous les
sens rennes sont bien sûr et donc
évidemment que c'est du proxénétisme
qu'est ce que c'est d'autres c'est dire
si vous voulez vous faire de l'argent
passé par le site ça c'est un improbable
à prendre sa part et vous allez pouvoir
avoir un délit
action en justice mais sur la base de sa
le procureur devrait dire vous les
arrêter vous fermez loyer marlène
schiappa geneviève ça nous avait
habitués à être un peu parce que je suis
médusé qu'elles gagnent pas plus fort je
comprends pas mais roanne
vous nous avez rejoint vous êtes au
service réseaux sociaux le figaro.fr
alors pourquoi on parle de cette affaire
c'est que c'est très commentée c'est
très agitée dans les réseaux sociaux
depuis ce matin c'est l'un des sujets
les plus commentés sur twitter est en
fait ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que ce
site est arrivé récemment en france et
dans une trentaine d'autres pays c'est
un site scandinaves et s'est
littéralement le meilleur coup de pub
qu'il ait pu avoir en fait parmi parmi
les sujets du moment
alors moi j'ai été voir le site internet
en question derrière cette publicité et
je me suis créé un profil pour voir à
quoi ressemblait cette étrange site dont
on parlait et la description abuseurs
étonnante non je ne suis pas inscrire ou
pour des trois personnes avec moi si je
me suis définit comme un sugar baby donc
c'est moi qui ai besoin d'argent et ont
défini les personnes sugar babies comme
des personnes qui n'ont pas peur de
définir exactement ce qu'ils attendent
de leurs partenaires sur le coup je me
suis dit qu'est ce qu'ils veulent dire
je suis allé un peu plus loin j'ai
rempli mon profil comme d'autres sites
de rencontres traditionnelles et en fait
après avoir décrit mes caractéristiques
physiques on me demande mon style de vie
comprenez prétentions salariales ça va
de 5000 euros à peu près par mois à plus
de 10000 euros je sais pas quelle école
de commerce demande plus de 10000 euros
par mois mais bon donc sur le site on
n'y trouve pas mal de jeunes
d'ailleurs c'est la plupart des profils
que j'ai pu constater des jeunes qui ont
besoin d'argent en france ou ailleurs et
on a déjà une pétition sur internet qui
a été lancé et qui recueille plus de
2600 signatures pour fermer ce site et
j'ai demandé à nos internautes via le
compte twitter du figaro étudiant ce
qu'ils en pensaient et à notre question
ils ont étaient 57% à être choqué de
cette publicité devant l'université
paris descartes
parmi nos internautes on a notamment mal
vu qui nous dit ce camion une
provocation que je considère cependant
comme positive il attire l'opinion sur
des faits terribles qui existe depuis
longtemps pour arrondir les fins de mois
de certains étudiants dans le besoin
on a à jarny coton aussi qui nous dit
marlène schiappa et faussement perplexes
ou interrogative si réellement il
s'agissait d'un mécénat de la part de
monsieur riche subventionnant de manière
désintéressée de jeunes étudiantes
pourquoi ne pas passer directement à la
fac mais les tweets les plus relayée sur
twitter
hormis des articles de presse ce sont
des personnalités des médias ou des
journalistes eux mêmes qui dénoncent le
fait d'en parler
on a notamment fabrice pelosi qui nous
dit bravo aux héros de twitter qui ont
délaissé dénoncé la pub ça a fait
l'ouverture du journal de la matinale de
france inter
on a aidé or de maréchal journaliste au
figaro qui dénonçait un tweet de nicolas
poincaré qui nous dit européen dénonce
ce matin le site sugar daddy qui du coup
daddy pardon qui du coup vient faire sa
pub sous les fenêtres de la radio notre
journaliste ne répond pub qui du coup
est gracieusement relayé par vos sens
sur les réseaux sociaux
halak avec hacker le tweet y répond et
par vous du goût on n'en finit plus fort
et encore bonjour la distance je
l'assumé mais on a le compteur un nageur
du figaro étudiant qui a pu repérer
quelque chose d'assez dramatique c'est
que le site en question qui s'en sert
tranquillement dans kloster google news
alors que le google news c'est la partie
de google qui référence les articles de
presse du jour on pouvait pas rêver
meilleure pub et c'est ce que l'on
continue à faire transformer mène alors
comment dénoncer quelque chose sans en
faire la promotion qui indirectement
vous avez quatre heures et demie à une
troisième hypothèse christophe denis
rioux qui est un spécialiste
quand même pas la question n'aurait pas
de la question d'une heure maintenant je
demanderai pas si c'est la version
moderne du viewer bons qu'ils
recherchent les oies blanches mais
est-ce que c'est pas un stade d'une
question provocatrice est ce que c'est
pas un stade ultime du libéralisme
et puis et en particulier du libéralisme
venus d'europe du nord ou bien de qui
qui s'illustrent qui s'illustrent là
c'est sûr que par exemple aux pays bas
dont certains de ces pays de ce système
est tout à fait tolérer fameuse
tolérance accepté en effet sous le nom
d' escort et puis on
il ya plein de choses qui peuvent
éventuellement se mettre derrière mais
j'aime pas le mot libéralisme pour cela
je parlerais plutôt de marchandisation
c'est à dire que ce que un petit peu ce
que disait olivier duhamel a cessé de
l'idée du richesse c'est ce que carole
la marchandisation des corps en
l'occurrence il s'agit bien de ça c'est
à dire les changes de son corps contre
une rémunération
et ça c'est quelque chose qui marque qui
me paraît beaucoup plus de mots qui me
paraît beaucoup plus approprié que le
mot libéralisme
parce que le libéralisme vous pouvez
dire tout adam smith pouvait lire tout
jeune rôle se trouverait jamais un
encouragement à ce genre de pratique
juste une dernière précision on trouve
en suisse à genève
ou bien aux pays-bas de la prostitution
quasiment légaliser c'est pour ça que je
pose la question
oui mais alors là après rendant un sujet
plus vaste parce que le point sur lequel
on peut s'accorder
c'est le terme qui a été utilisé un
produit par carole barjon c'est
proxénétisme
ce site est un site proxénète voilà
après la prostitution lips est un autre
sujet et à nos débats a pas le lancer
maintenant t'es bon on leur lancera une
prochaine fois
merci beaucoup mais roanne